Okay, welcome back.
So, Ice Cube and Common
are in the new Barbershop movie
and I wanted to talk to them
and I was thinking
hmm, where should we
do the interview?
Uh, I know-- a malt shop.
No.
Maybe a tool and die shop?
Mm...
And then it hit me--
(scoffs) A coffee shop.
Well, uh, we couldn't find one,
so we settled for a barbershop.
And I thought we'd have
a real conversation about race
and some of the issues
in the community.
♪ ♪
Hey, everybody. I'm here
at Little Tony & Igor Be Good
barbershop with Ice Cube and
Common, stars of the new movie,
uh, Barbershop. Is it
Barbershop 8? Which one is it?
It's Barbershop: The Next Cut.
Full disclosure:
we're not technically
in a black barbershop.
I don't know what the hours are
at black barbershops.
You take your chances
when you go there,
that's all I'm saying.
Well, since we're in a
barbershop, let's talk about
the significance of the place.
Why do you think the barbershop
means so much
in the black community?
It's our only country club.
It's the only place you can go
and kind of get that fellowship
and that camaraderie.
People is gonna
give it to you raw.
Like, that's what it is.
Like, it's authentic
in the barbershop.
-It's authentic, right?
-Yeah.
WILMORE: Now, race is talked
about a lot in barbershops.
Like, you... Where do you think
we are, let's say,
on the (bleep)
with attitude scale?
Like, should (bleep)
still have a lot of attitude?
Middle attitude? Just...
I mean, I think they should have
the same amount of attitude,
because the days on the calendar
change but, you know,
our situation
is not changing, you know,
as a-as a people
on a whole lot of levels.
Why do you think that is?
What's going on with that?
I mean, people thought
when Obama came in,
-you know, racism was over.
-Yeah, yeah. Well, I think
you know, um,
somehow we had a hope
that it was going to just stop.
And, I mean,
he obviously did every...
is doing everything he can,
but it still can't change
the minds of deep-rooted racism
that's been in the system for so
long and people, they feel that.
Though you have...
you have Obamas,
you have the-the Jay Zs
and Beyoncés--
you know, successful people,
you know,
There's still people
that we're connected to
-that still have issues,
you -know? So... -Right.
Just because you're successful,
you shouldn't
-forget about that those
issues exist. -Yeah, -exact...
And-and look
what we're successful in--
-you know, sports
and entertainment. -Right.
You know, it's like, uh,
Chris Rock said, you know, uh,
"You know, I'm-I'm a big-time,
worldwide comedian,
"and the guy that lives
next door to me
"is a white dentist.
Why couldn't I just be a dentist
"and make it to this
neighborhood? I had to be
a big-time celebrity to get
here, and the guy next door..."
But seriously, Cube, you don't
want to go to a black dentist,
let's be honest.
-Of course you do.
-Yeah, I do.
-But I'm-but I'm saying...
-Let's be honest.
-But...
-Let's be clear about this.
Oh, no.
I want to talk about the black
community itself
and some of the issues
that are facing...
Especially in the last few
years, some have come up
more than others. And, um,
I see it... A lot of people
pit gang violence, what's
happening in the community,
-versus police violence,
you know? -Yeah.
And people kind of get it...
They make this comparison
-all the time, you know?
-Yeah. -Yeah.
Um, why do you think
people feel the need to do that?
Um, you know, I-I think
it's really kind of ridiculous
when you compare
apples and oranges like that.
Citizen on citizen crime
is totally different
than government
on citizen crime.
By the way, that's a criminal's
job-- is to ma...
is to commit crime.
That's his job.
-Yeah, without a doubt. -They're
just showing up for work.
-Without a doubt.
-Right?
-Police are supposed to protect
and serve. -Protect and serve.
You guys are not doing your job.
The criminal's doing his job.
-Right?
-Yeah. -Yeah. Yeah, man.
It was once said,
"Serve, protect
-and break a (bleep) neck."
-I mean, the police feel like
-they're, uh... it's an us
against them mentality. -Right.
You know? And they always talk
about no snitchin', you know?
-No snitchin' in the hood.
-Right, right, right.
You know, they...
Why won't they tell us
when there's a crime
committed in the hood?
These people never speak.
These people are never
gonna say nothing when we
go and ask them who did it.
There's a no-snitchin' policy
in the hood,
but it's a no-snitchin' policy
in the precinct, too.
-That's exactly right.
-Because when they see
their fellow officers
doing something wrong,
they don't snitch,
they don't tell,
they-they keep it to themselves,
so how do they expect us
to not have a no-snitchin'
policy in the neighborhood
when they got a no-snitchin'
policy in the department?
Maybe we can all
come together and agree that
there should not be snitches.
We could start a no-snitchin'
police outreach program.
Yeah, without...
without a doubt.
Let me ask you this last
question about your movie, okay?
What-what was it like working
with Nicki Minaj?
I don't know how much acting
she's done. I'll tell you what,
describe Nicki Minaj
in 750 words.
(laughter)
I mean, you know, great.
-Good luck with the movie, too.
-Appreciate it.
Thank you, man.
Thanks again to Common and Ice
Cube for sitting down with me.
Go see Barbershop, you guys, The
Next Cut! We'll be right back!
(cheering and applause)